ciao a tutti allora ragazzi oggi
parliamo di una cosa scegli un video che
c'è un video serie strano è incredibile
senato
ho conosciuto questo ragazzo tramite
instagram che fa dei degli artworks dei
mosaici con i cubi di rubik che mi
contornano come se fosse un'opera d'arte
quali sono questo ragazzo è anche molto
conosciuto all'estero agli ha ripostato
gli hanno riportato i lavori tipo will
smith cioè il sacco di gente conosciuta
e quindi passando la gente poco
conosciuta come will smith siamo
arrivati finalmente al più conosciuto
del mondo oggi è qui con noi
giovanni allora ciao ciao ragazzi lui e
giovanni che fa queste cose fantastiche
e adesso vi faccio vedere un paio di
rowe perché famiglie la password del
telefono zio questo ad esempio e il suo
profilo instagram e lui fa tutti questi
mosaici con i cubi di rubik
ci siamo sentiti tramite instagram è
oggi facciamo la fan art fan art for
heart
quindi io prima di cominciare avrei due
o tre domande se c'è la foto spara spara
non fritte aspetta in quanti secondi
riesce a fare il cubo di rubik
normalmente è intorno agli 8 9 secondi a
volte 10 tra le otto ore
capito cosa ho scritto io quanto tempo
invece impieghi per fare un un artwork
allora diciamo da in generale da un
concetto a un prodotto finito
simona ricciolino settimane però la
l'atto in cui ho finito il design e lo
ricrea come faremo oggi che meno 2 3 ore
allora io prima di cominciare vorrei
mostrarvi la mia bravura
mi permetto di prenderne uno credo
scombinare ancora molti e lore lei lo
fai a smontarlo così è impossibile
giampiero inediti mi metti la velocità
per per cento così sembra che
signor b grazie grazie grazie
adesso sta attaccando le insegne questo
metodo assolutamente faccia mi dai 45
ore ci sono e non va bene questo lo
mettiamo qua quindi sentito la meglio
qui direi che se in sei d'accordo
possiamo iniziare con l'arco e l'artwork
va benissimo benissimo a chiudere un po
[Musica]
mi sento molto me larghezza cominciare
questa cosa però io non avevo capito che
lui cioè io pensavo che più li mettesse
tutti fatti nei posti giusti no invece
non del libro con smontare il cubo e fa
il singolo pixel e il pixel del cupolone
il cubo stesso e non avevo capito scuola
perfetto quindi ancora più un casino
[Musica]
allora siccome abbiamo stoppato aido
fastidio ai cameraman che milano non
sono male mentre vengo vicino alla
videocamera
volevo dirvi ci siamo fermati un attimo
io e giovanni perché dobbiamo fare una
foto su instagram per poggiare questo
video la domanda che mi è venuta e che
mi è venuta in mente mentre lo stai
facendo questo lavoro è quanto è
orribile dover fissare la mia faccia per
tutto questo tempo ma guarda guarda te
lo dirò una volta finita ovviamente non
ti voglio vedere per altri quattro anni
però se 56 volto alla gente gentilissimo
bene facciamo questa foto
[Musica]
senti sono veramente stanco vado a
prendere un attimo un caffè mi me lo fai
tu nel frattempo io vado in grado e non
devi riuscire allora fai un po fi poco
poi ci penso io voi un caffè dopo te lo
vorrei che se fai casini amico mio
e ora di attirare le nostre conclusioni
quindi il capolavoro direi perché non si
può descrivere diversamente è finito
ringrazio mi stesso per aver fatto tutto
il tutto c'è stata una disgrazia e mille
davvero a parte gli scherzi sei un
fenomeno impressioni a caldo come
secondo tempo fatto il meglio che potevo
farci bene quindi dai ragazzi per ogni
video vi sia piaciuto
ora visto che abbiamo fatto tutto questo
mega capolavoro guarda soluzioni una e
facciamo un bel riquadro di legno
tuttora fermi nato
lo apprendiamo loro oppure ero di
stradale
[Musica]
volevo chiedergli semplicemente non è
che siccome la mia faccia e quella non è
che puoi farmi diventare tipo will smith
mi ricambia il naso perché sai si
compone di farmi niente a livello
diciamo pixel per pixel di lo possa
cambiare un po tutto però miracoli mi sa
quindi posso fare mi dispiace
[Musica]